my dear brothers and sisters may Allah
bless you all I'm going to take a break
from speakers now cuz recently I've been
going back to my original state Algerian
style you know some n some nervous angry
I need to calm down a bit but anyway I
want to mention some points like I said
I'm going to take break cuz it's needed
speak you been here for a long time you
know every year you have to take
sometime out from speak Corner either
one month two months anyway what I speak
I speak about
uh you know there's things I want to
mention which very very important one of
them sometimes when you give da to woman
here you know sometimes we have brothers
you know they like the circle is too
close and the reason I'm speaking about
is because I don't want some young
Brothers out there looking up to us even
we M watching they it's okay to speak to
woman come close to her all of that no
it's not okay try your best we ask SCH
one of the major schar of our time is
over 90 or something you know he was a
teacher in Medina he stopped because
very old and he said yes she doesn't
have to cover her face or herself before
you give a DA because she's a
nonbeliever but however in speak now we
have to make rules that if we speaking
to woman giv a DA firstly make sure you
you blur her face don't put my face and
woman's face in a f I'm not happy with
that I'm not pleased with that I'm free
from that you know secondly remind me
because some I forget remind me let us
go to an area when there's more space
and there's no one behind the woman cuz
sometimes even some sisters you know
they want to ask questions so we have to
give them show them respect Muslims are
non-muslim women show respect to the
Muslim woman and a non-muslim woman so
we should not be as sometimes many
brothers behind the woman and Too Close
Subhan Allah I I will not be happy for
my wife or my sister or my daughter
likewise I'm be happy for my sister
Islam so we have to remind each other
the other brothers because why like I
said there are some young Brothers out
there think it's okay so when he go he
does he goes and DM sister on Tik Tok or
or Facebook or or Instagram claim Shi or
brother so and so giving da there was a
woman okay so we have to I'm not perfect
but if I believe there's something which
is incorrect I openly come out and say
I'm wrong in doing this cuz Islam above
me it's not about myself this Islam
that's the first thing the second thing
I was going to mention my dear brother
and Allah bless you all that last week I
was speaking to and uh he asked me do
you believe that I should be killed so I
said to him if you if you go to a Muslim
country and there's leaders and Scholars
and they pass judgment to then according
to you should be killed if you say no
you're going against thei yourself
likewise he believe I'm I'm an agent
According to Islamic teaching if I'm an
agent working for a zist I should be
killed but he was scared to say it
because he's a hypocrite you understand
thirdly my dear brothers and sisters
speaking about the issue of politics big
issues doesn't belong to someone who is
a kitten in front of front of me who was
a kitten then he went online start
talking too much what he did that person
last week he became liberal democracy he
start asking people what do you think
about peace treaty the majority vote
majority vote that's democracy even
though I told him the verse in the Quran
which clearly he wouldest it to show you
who's following the Quran and
alhamdulillah and the other thing I was
going to to mention some brother said to
me we don't debate why you debating him
brother I was I was just confronting him
to be honest I couldn't take it this man
act like a lion online like you know
like a gorilla the guy came here like a
kitten acting like he just helping for
people to help he was asking people to
help him so anyway may Allah guide him
but there's a lot of lies but anyway
like I I'm going to take a break may
Allah bless you all so this point I want
to mention also reminder to my brother
and out there be aware of speaking to
sisters or S sister speaking to Brothers
on Instagram Facebook of necessity yes
with restriction but is a f even even my
sister says even if someone is a scholar
you have to fear Allah okay because he's
a man the end of the day he's a man okay
so we as a brothers and sisters we have
to help one another to not put each
other into
F so because the Calamity sometimes I
speak to a brother he said yeah the
sister you speaking to onl on speak K
she's my friend on Instagram your friend
on Instagram what does that mean is your
friend yes if you a and you have people
following you even that we have to
including myself please this for me
including myself we have to Fe Allah and
we have to be careful you know that's
why you're not having your own personal
thing is
dangerous so just a reminder bless you
my dear brothers and sisters and my
sisters if you don't have to come here
don't come if you come of necessity then
there's etiquette go get the brother he
want to speak to bring someone with him
go outside don't start in between a man
may Allah forgive them I know they want
to listen but we have to accommodate a
way for sisters to benefit without them
mixing with a man may Allah bless you
all and hopefully we see you soon uh
this was a clarification to the Nation
about the situation because it's an
obligation from The Lord of the
creation one more go ahead what are some
methods of making Dua for the brothers
and we have to make Dua so one of the
mentioned the etiquette of making Dua
okay I'm not sure if this recorded is it
recorded happen to the light anyway
there's etiquette one of them
making secondly making W thirdly giving
charity fourthly uh make sure you ask
you make a Dua in a time which is must
between and third of the night um
likewise when it's raining or traveling
also make sure your your cloths is not
you didn't you don't buy those clothes
from Haram money okay make sure you you
eat Halal and dress buy clothes with Hal
money the other one you praise allaha
glorify him send IIM then you start
asking Allah with the condition of your
heart you make Dua and you thinking
about someone else Focus so there
some mentioned in
his which I highly recommend for my dear
brothers and S sisters may Allah bless
you all to purchase me myself we went
through it we studyed together in all of
it and the best translation is
translation by publication the
brother may
bless up and your children and everybody
to do yes said that to to wake up and
wake up your family to do
and like we did today first
time every prayer someone said no
specifically for and you make a Dua for
our brothers and sister cuz it's very
sad what's happening to them it's not a
joke two days ago I'm laying down in my
bed and my wife told me there's a
licking and I start becoming stressed
licking This Woman Upstairs keep keep
living the water the to on imagine your
house being destroyed and your children
they have no place no
food so that's why other than them he
said we the go to war they have to
prepare themselves not just for
themselves to protect themselves but to
protect the Muslims said if you take the
Muslims to war and you know they're
going to is going to cause greater harm
upon the Muslims that's not the Jihad
which Allah told us about what already
happened preserve him said the people of
they have nowhere to go so they have to
fight if they they try their best to
stay away from it if they can but if
someone come to if the zist come to kill
them they have to fight even with the
stones with everything you know that and
this is a clear reputation against the
Liars who said that the salais they say
if someone come to kill you tell him
wait let
me lie look what said because this
called it's our necessity if you have
somewhere to go they can go but they
have nowhere this Satan has besieged
them everywhere and we ask the mus we
ask Allah to unite the Muslim leaders
you know to in order to fight and defend
our brothers and sisters in Gaza and phe
and in China and everywhere and Subhan
Allah what's happening to us told us
when we turn away from Allah and you
know but alhamdulillah you take many
lessons from our brothers and
sisters we ask Allah with his beautiful
names and the love to
attribute
for